how do you place objects in a world in
an interesting way because it's a big
part we have a level design you cannot
people well if they only knew how much
we spend on we have a clutter group a
group people who clutter
like we like clutter is all the stuff
around just like interior decorators
yeah for Treasure and stuff and trash
and
um they go through every space and they
clutter it our level designers think
about it a lot these also become
landmarks for the player when you're
walking through a space and oh this is
the place with this and there is a logic
to making a good level
um as they say with even if you walk by
like a little T intersection that
becomes like a decision point in the
player's head like oh I didn't go down
that way but the more you do that it
looks easy on paper but when you're
playing a game
you actually kind of want to limit those
because he's trying to keep track of all
these decision points then they get lost
and yes we have Maps but anytime the
player is going to check a map in a
place like that I feel that it's more of
like a backstop for certain players if
we if they need to check the map feel
like we've kind of failed
got it so it's just there's a there's a
momentum to it just pulls pulls them in
and you know if you played a lot of
games you played a lot of levels where
you're just like I'm a little confused
or I don't know and you play other
levels where like man I just I yeah it
was great I went through it it was well
balanced I knew where I was going and
it's not you don't want to ever be Maisy
as long as you know where you're going
as long as you know you made those
choices then
it feels fine but as far as the treasure
and all of the loot
um it is really an art we will not do
enough clutter and then we will over
clutter and then there's too much stuff
everywhere and then we declutter every
single game I wish we got better at it
it would save us a lot of time but your
constant gone by feel like this is not
as too much it's not enough right right
because the other thing is
look it creates
um
people want to pick everything up they
want to click everything
so if you have too many things of
importance in a room it's like it
actually makes you feel a little tight
as a player you're like well I need I'm
basically an idiot if I don't pick all
this stuff up here you probably felt
this way yeah yeah for sure and like the
moment where you decide that you're just
like I've clicked so many things in this
room I actually am going to leave that
ammo canister there yeah but you feel
like a dope yeah
you've probably experienced it yes but
also you have a you have a joy from if
there's not many items and you found the
one and you got it right and you feel
good I got it and then it's finding like
oh I stuck my head in this corner and
you know I picked this lock and I open
this locker and oh there was this
there's this thing I've been waiting for
yeah
what about like rare and rare items
that's an art even more so of an art
um I will say we have a ways to go there
in terms of finding the right drop rate
for special items we call them in your
epic rare legendary
you look at games like so many games do
it and there are ones that P you just
play and love because they have it down
you know Destiny Destiny 2 is great at
it Diablo
a series I love you know sort of
famously Diablo 3 which I think is great
and they did an update it mostly just
changed the loot drops and it's like
this whole new experience and there's a
really real art to it
um I think that that we're still
learning we're still learning a lot and
have to we're trying to you know get
better at it because it's one of those
things where it drives you through the
game it's it's fun to get the treasure
in Diablo and Skyrim have this
interesting quality of
being extremely popular
and there's a lore around like rare
items so it's a it changes the dynamic
of like you could afford to have really
rare items yes and then and then
somebody finds it and that becomes like
a thing I mean as you release a game
there's a there's a I mean a lot of
people play and they start sharing
stories and so on it's so interesting
because that's part of the game
experience is the stories of others
right for us a hundred percent because
we've been classically with most of our
stuff single player that that water
cooler shared experience we would have a
thing like where we call them did you
know moments like we gotta have a bunch
so you meet someone they do what are you
doing and then they say did you know
if you go here and do this what did you
know
and that to us uh is aware of a lot of
our community
has has been sharing their stories and
here's what you can do